a final push into rebel-held villages
after senegal's armed forces launched a
two-week ground
and aerial assault government troops
have taken back control of southern
districts in the kazamas region
bordering guinea-bissau
this is an important operation aimed at
better controlling the border
by creating military outposts deep in
the jungle this is to allow the civilian
population that flood the area to be
able to finally return home
this is what's left of one of the rebel
bases provisions and arms were abandoned
as senegal government forces launched
their surprise assault
the army says rebel fighters had placed
land mines
all around the camp
at least one officer in our ranks was
injured when he stepped on an
anti-personnel mine
also one of our comrades was injured by
gunshots
the movement of democratic forces of
kazamas also known as the mfdc has been
fighting for independence from senegal
for the last 40 years
in the past the government of
guinea-bissau and gambia were hostile
towards senegal and supported the rebels
a spokesperson of the senegalese armed
forces told al jazeera
that they suspect the rebels of having
fled
to neighboring guinea-bissau while there
has been
series of victories for the senegalese
army
in the last year lasting peace will
require the cooperation
of neighboring countries but newly
elected presidents in neighboring
countries stopped funding the rebels
preferring to build
stronger ties with senegal's president
mike sal
today senegal has good allies
both in guinea south and the gambia so
it is
let's say the best time for the
senegalese government
to find
lasting solution to the cosmos conflict
which means using the military
depression
while negotiating with a very weak mldc
following mediation efforts by
organizations close to the vatican
the movement of democratic forces of
kazamas called for a full
cease-fire in 2014 but the rebels are
accused by rights groups and
environmentalists
of illegal logging and attacking local
villagers
this latest assault by the senegalese
army is another attempt
to bring this long-standing conflict to
an end
nicholas hawk al-jazeera dakar